hey guys mkbhd here as many of you know
i go by mkbhd on youtube which is my
initials plus hd because i happen to
upload most of my videos in the highest
quality or one of the highest qualities
that youtube can allow and that's high
definition video i actually upload in
720p hd now i know that a lot of you
guys want to upload high definition
videos but don't necessarily have an hd
camcorder so today i'm going to be
giving you a demonstration of a piece of
software in the screencast form that'll
actually help you be able to fake hd now
this isn't recommended at all really but
this is just to give you an idea of the
way that you can get your videos to be
in hd the next episode of youtube tips
by the way will cover cameras and of
course hd camcorders so yeah thumbs up
for that all you're going to need for
this quick tutorial is your original
non-hd video and a piece of software
that's available on windows and mac os
10 and linux called mpeg stream clip and
make sure that to be able to use this
you have apple's quicktime installed but
yeah mpeg streamflip is the name of the
software that we're going to be using to
do this
so here on our desktop we have a 640 by
480 video standard non hd resolution and
if we blow this up to the full size of
the 1280 by 720 player you can see that
it would have those bars on the left and
right hand side the black bars of course
that's no problem because this method
that we're going to do will solve that
so making sure you have your handy dandy
mpeg stream clip installed go ahead and
open it up and follow these instructions
in the software go to file open file and
locate that movie that you shot in
640x480
when you open it up you'll be able to
move right on through it and see that
that is in fact the video that you shot
now the following steps you can alter to
your own preference but we can go to
file export to quicktime and begin
messing with these settings here we're
going to export to h.264 and drag
quality all the way up to a hundred
percent be sure to insert the frame rate
that you shot the video at which is 60
here and select 1280 by 720 or 720p over
on the left hand side when you're done
you just hit make movie name your export
and hit the save button and you will
begin to start your export of your new
stretched 720p video
so yeah as you can see using this type
of video
stretching kind of gives it a sort of a
wide appearance to it it's not really
recommended like i said which is why
i'll be giving you guys a lot of camera
tips and especially camera buying guide
tips to help you guys avoid having to
use the solution but this definitely
works a lot better with screencasts
where you can't usually tell when a
video has been stretched or not
that's better so that's about it guys
for this mkbhd video in the next video
which is youtube tips episode we'll be
covering what kind of equipment you use
to use to shoot actual true hd video the
methods i showed you earlier are really
basically for screencasters or for those
who don't mind the slight distortion of
stretching a 4x3 video to widescreen so
until next time mkbhd signing out peace